Train by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Where's Shane Carwyn going?
Shane Carlin's going Arisun.
Okay.
Yeah,
he couldn't take it no more.
The silence.
He's like,
fuck it.
I guess he wants to have some fun while he's still shame.
Carwyn I salute that he could still hit harder than McKinney did.
Did you see that Jason Ellis fight?
Do you see what crazy Jason Ellis did?
Jay Snell is fought.
Shane Carwyn with one hand tied up.
Shane.
Karlyn had his right hand tied up to his body and so Jason,
I was like,
you don't realize how big Shane Carwyn is.
Like Jason Nelson is not the tiniest guy.
You know,
he's probably about 200 pounds.
Who any stand next to Shane Carwyn.
It is almost comical how it look at this.
Look how big car one is.
I mean,
he's a giant.
He's a fucking giant and he's got one arm tied up.
Look at this and he looks good dude.
Like physically,
he looks jacked.
Like he hasn't fought in a while,
but obviously he's been working out.
I mean he looks better than he did the did the last time I saw him,
the last time I saw him,
he was a recovering from some injuries and he was still in the UFC.
So apparently he's a free agent and I think,
you know,
he's,
he's fighting for rise and I'm pretty sure,
I mean,
I know we put it on his Instagram page,
but uh,
he k man,
he,
it's really kind of wrong.
Look,
oh,
that was one,
that was one punch.
Did he hit him with that wasn't even though the punch at that k Odom is it?
No,
that,
that was like at the end of around,
I think,
see this is where it k Odom right here.
So that was the second one.
I mean that one really Kayo and I'm like,
you could see when he was down he was like,
fuck.
I mean that guy is so God damn big.
Carlin's a gigantic human.
So they were talking about setting him up with,
or like fate or versus car when,
I don't know if that's gonna happen,
but if that does,
I'm in,
I'm paying to see that that's a dangerous fight for faith for dangerous fires.
Right.
Japan,
it's essentially the same guy who was a charge of a pride for awhile.
Yeah.
And uh,
I believe so.
And so,
uh,
if he goes over and fights,
if Carl and goes over and fights in Japan and he fights fade or as a giant fight
last time,
afraid off,
fought,
fought Fabio Maldonado and barely squeaked by a fight,
a lot of people thought that he should have lost you got hurt.
Fabio Maldonado tagged them and there's no shame in that.
Fabio [inaudible],
Fabio Maldonado is a very good boxer.
He rocked Glover to share before glow over,
finished him off.
And uh,
he's just tough as shit and he's a tough,
tough guy.
They always call that poor guy in like,
they always,
Fabio Fabio's like,
who are we going to get old fighter who will be this fucking wacky fight on
short notice?
Fabio Maldonado,
you remember how he saved that fight in Australia?
In Brazil?
Some way.
Phots steep bay at heavyweight steep Emile chick when Steve Bay's is just
fucking tearing through the ranks.
Right.
Steve Bay's trying to get a shot at the title and he fights Fabio Maldonado.
I just,
I mean,
Steve Bay just ran through them.
It was horrific.
And Steve,
but he's a scary guy as a heavyweight and Fabio Maldonado just was not the same
size,
just did not belong in there with them.
You know,
just too big,
too strong,
too fast.
It's too hard.
It was a scary fight.
But um,
when you think about Fabio Rock and Faye door and hurting him and his last fight
and you think good lord would if he gets hit by Carwyn like car car when takes a
great shot and he hits harder than anybody in the division.
He's,
he's probably,
he's probably one of the scariest heavyweight punchers ever.
Literally ever when he fought mirror,
I remember he,
he tied near up in a clinch and just ripped up,
cuts to his chin,
his face and put them down and just beat him down when he's on the ground.
Like Carwyn could Faulk and paunch scary punch her man.
So if he's healthy like he looks like and that video,
it looks fucking healthy to me and he looks huge.
It looks like he's like well over to 60.
Yeah,
I dunno fader.
I Dunno if that's the kind of fight he wants at this stage of his life.
You know,
after he fought Maldonado,
he might be looking to fight smaller heavyweights.
He might be looking to fight bigger names,
will actually comments pretty God damn big name as far as the free market.
But who knows what's going to happen,
man.
You know,
with,
um,
one of the crazy things with all these new organizations,
whether it's one FC,
whether it's,
uh,
you know,
fill in the blank Bella tour,
rise in all these other,
like everyone is scrambling to pick up anybody who leaves the UFC.
So if people's contracts are up,
like they're starting to do and they start bolting over and go into these other
different organizations,
stuff can get crazy.
Like things can heat up and you might see like another pride UFC type rivalry,
which I think would be great for everybody.
Like if if rise and really does take off,
like if rise and puts on fate or versus shame Carwyn and then they come up with
a bunch of other crazy fights for the undercard,
you know,
just,
there's just not right now the same level of talent available outside the UFC.
Not right now,
but man,
it's been close a few times and it used to be,
you know,
obviously it used to be with pride.
It's hard to make it something like that happen,
you know,
I feel with like a Shane car when,
for example,
Shane carn was a great fighter.
He hasn't thrown a punch in how many years?
Um,
he hasn't fought MMA since,
I want to say it's two years ago.
Two,
three years.
Okay.
If the,
in my world,
I dunno,
I'm not the professional here,
but I think the UFC marketing would know.
They could do something with a Shane cow and if they,
if they passed on them,
maybe there's something they can do.
The heavyweight division is packed.
I Dunno.
Parameters of this,
you know,
I feel like when a fighter hasn't fought more than a year or two or maybe even
three,
I think about comedy.
Joe Rogan,
when I think about it,
probably just didn't do any company for three years.
What would I be ready for?
What would you,
you didn't do any comedy for three years.
What would you honestly book yourself for and fucking December.
It's October 31st what would you book yourself on the December the garden,
you know,
you do like the laughing skull and Atlanta.
Okay.
A nice cool intimate little room.
Very quiet.
99 Cedar.
Shane might not have a lot of money and the rising might have offered them a big
chat.
No,
I understand all these parameters,
but I'm saying to you is,
you know,
it's like the GSP thing that was going on and maybe they weren't what they were.
And I think even as a finer two,
three years,
shit is fucking change.
I can change.
Yes and no.
Here's the no,
depends on if you're still training,
see if you decide to take some time off because you have nagging injuries or
some fighters like that.
Joseph volatility and you guy were talking about earlier,
he stepped back because of concussion syndrome cause he's getting,
he,
you know,
he had too many hits to the head and so he recognized it was having some real
symptoms and he said no I have to resign.
So he,
he gave up his belt and taking two or three years off if you're having any sort
of real problem,
maybe if you've got a reoccurring back injury,
which I know Shane had some back issues.
He even had surgery.
Yes.
So maybe taking that time off.
So it was junior dos Santos was his last loss and that was UFC one 31 and wow.
2011.
So that's five fucking years ago.
Fucking the Fado I love him to death.
You know,
I caught the tail and the Fado,
you know,
I caught like the two fights before he got on board.
Right by a boy.
Well he got our bart first.
And you saw the fights that he won before that?
Yeah,
like two fights.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
he beat Brett Rogers and then,
um,
I think the next fight after Brett Rogers,
pretty sure it was fair to him.
I didn't catch fade or in his hay day is what I'm trying to say.
So the last couple of times I went,
it was like how people said they wanted,
they went to watch x at the end and they got all excited.
It went down so a lot.
And then he got submitted by,
uh,
for doom,
the doom.
What you and I discussed it this could fucking be doing for him.
He's got a nasty guard.
There's another guy we were talking about yet.
Nasty guard.
Yeah.
So then I saw a couple pieces of the last fight that was fucking embarrassing.
That was fucked up,
both of them.
But at the Fabio I love,
I love his fucking jaw that he takes a fight at short notice and then he fought
that Indian gentlemen before that.
Yeah.
So,
but Fado I mean,
now you just,
we're exploiting the guy and that's how people get hurt.
I don't think freight all wants to fight.
If he would've,
he fought for fucking years and he killed was killing people and all of a sudden
he didn't fight for one.
My wants to make a comeback.
I don't know.
His brother got out of jail.
His brother just got out of jail.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Okay.
I did read that and get ready to fight.
Say you're doing nothing but pushups.
Yeah.
Working out in jail still come out.
Jack new tattoos.
I like,
if he wants to fight,
I want them to be able to fight.
Just like I wanted them to be able to fight when he was 20 I want to deal with a
fight when he's 40 if he wants to.
Why not?
Okay.